my name is Chris Adams I'm a globe maker
and I've been making globes for best
part of 14 years now to make a globe you
start off with a mold and you make a
very wet mix of plaster and swirl it
around to make sure there's a uniform
coverage of plaster in the mold when
that is dry you then make a second mix a
wet mix and pour that in and reinforce
it with paper they used to muse card or
various other materials but I found
papers best it's lightweight and still
retains its strength when that is dry
its blown out of the mold and the two
halves are joined together let's send it
down rub down until the very smooth and
given a final coat of shellac to
strengthen it and to seal it at this
stage the map will be applied
they're called gauze there are usually
12 cores that go around the globe they
are stretched onto the globe ensuring
all lines match up so there's no
overlaps as no under laps everything
should match up nicely one of the things
you have to bear in mind when applying a
Gore is the fact that the paper will
stretch it's designed to stretch two
percent in one direction it has to be
printed with that in mind you have to
reduce the the artwork of two percent to
a knife and scratch I've been doing it
for so long that it's quite easy for me
to apply the gauze and make the lines
match up and make sure they make sure
the paper behaves as I want it to
it's a skill that I've learnt and picked
up so I'd like to think I'm quite good
these places
once the goals have been applied they
have given my seal and then hand
coloured and tinted and unusually given
an age afterwards to make the globe to
the gold I prefer to think of it as
giving them a head start in the aging
process I tried to remain true to the
materials and methods of traditional
globe making obviously I improve where I
can a lot of materials they use
traditionally were and more based which
I like to move away from if I can the
plaster I use now is not dissimilar to
the plus that they used but it's far
stronger and harder wearing so it's it's
little things that they would have
incorporated as well if they have the
chance glyphs were traditionally
educational which perhaps isn't the case
these days but I think a globe still has
a role to play it's nice to have
something tangible in your hands to see
exactly where we are in the world where
we where we would like to go you can
spin a globe and see what's on the other
side of it from where you are which you
can't necessarily do from a monitor or a
book
you
you